alors joe vous avez une fille qui
s'appelle bonnut oui hein et elle doit
souvent vous posez des questions sur le
monde sur la vie sur les gens sur les
idées ouais c'est vrai ça va vous
falloir une interview expliqué à massy
en ébauche par le bouche pendant le
signal
[Applaudissements]
bien alors imaginez donc je suis votre
fille et je vous pose des questions pas
fâché il faut bien petite rubrique mais
bien un travail à faire mais bon je
pense pas que ce soit très compliqué
pour vous papa c'est quoi un bon bout là
c'est un petit gâteau d'un petit gâteau
qui s'est vendu dans les années 80
et il y avait un noir de 6,1 j'ai grandi
avec ça
c'était une catastrophe
et aussi le tête de [ __ ] encore en
pâtisserie qui se vend très bien
alors c'est étrange que ce soit
systématiquement sur une communauté en
particulier que ce type de choses
arrivent c'est vrai c'est regarder leur
effigie s'il n'y a pas d'autres
pâtisserie
il n'y a pas de tête de chinois ou
non c'est vrai que
rihanna grand chemise aussi
papa toujours votre fille à un boni
pourquoi tu t'es pas présenté pour être
maire de dreux
parce que comme dans beaucoup de villes
de france mon enfant tu sais
la droite s'est allié au front national
pour faire liste commune dès le premier
tour il faut se retirer faut se battre
contre ces gens là a donc je je suis
cette fois-ci retirer et apporter mon
soutien à la liste de jean pierre lesage
entre bombe contre la folie ambiante
c'était un régime bien me faire un bisou
voici ses réponses
du pape a dit moi papa c'est vrai que tu
vas être président de la république oui
je serai le prochain président ma fille
je serai aussi le dernier
parce que c'est moi qui vais
démissionner cette fonction sera plus de
président après il ya plus besoin de
président que je crois il ya plus de
prix a plus de frontières déjà 1,1
président de quoi mon beauf chacun des
présidents de chez soi chez sa carcasse
d d'accord avec ça je remarque
est ce qu'on devrait tous avoir une
carte de citoyen du monde et qui est
plus de frontières plus de pays puis de
président jean ont fait l'europe serait
pas mal 1 1 2 ont fait leur oeuvre c'est
pour çà président de la france bon ça
c'est pas complètement faux
mais dit pas que des conneries non
dit papa pour en bambou la voit pas
papa tu avais dit qu'avec jasper y
aurait plus de sans papiers et à la télé
on en voit encore
c'est mieux et c'est pas gagné c'est
clair et pourquoi toi papa on ne voit
plus trop à la télé
bassi regarde ma fille j'y vais et puis
parce que tu sais je fais j'ai fait des
films là j'ai joué au théâtre est venu
me voir il y aurait bien aimé le
spectacle était monté sur scène un
attila faire comme tu veux faire comme
ayant péri tension on fait attention
tout pourquoi pas parce que je veux
faire comme semi bugzy peux pas je vais
être acteur
et pas pourquoi il n'ya pas y'a pas
beaucoup de noirs à la télé
est belle ma fille tu sais ça s'est fait
doucement 1 il y avait un code noir il
ya une justice qui déterminait que
l'homme noir n'était pas égale à l'homme
blanc même un pape qui a dit que l'homme
noir n'avaient pas de conscience qui
sait ça remonte à l'ong à l'entente
revient lundi sa wii wheel dernier n'a
pas dit ça évidemment mais
mais il est issu d'une vieille tradition
et puis c'est un c'est un monde qui a
considéré que le bois renée n'était pas
un homme tu as use up et encore quand on
va chercher du boulot quand on va aux
loges et quand tu iras j'espère que ça
sera à ranger d'ici là mais tu aura plus
de problèmes que les autres il va y
avoir plus de noirs à la télé
oui je pense qu'il y en a déjà un peu
plus donc ça va mieux oui bien sûr
l'espoir les devants toute façon la
merdasse c'est derrière pas pourquoi le
président de république jacques chirac
il va pas voir le juge qui l'a convoqué
parce que tu sais mon enfant
en ce moment il ya une chose très
importante qui est en train de se passer
derrière ces artistes qui détient les
bonnes valeurs et la morale la justice
ou les élus strauss et plus tu essaies
on est dans un système en un temps cette
justice c'est la même qui emprisonne des
sans papiers qui tolère le commerce des
bombes et des armes
et de l'autre côté d'un homme qui lui
représentant commerce justement et puis
même temps celui étonnerait qu elle
parle de jacques chirac marque au lion
n'a jamais parlé
papa c'est quoi les verts pourquoi ils
sont pas tous vers les verts
allons peut être noir et vert regard
stéphane jacob et stéphane pocrain est
belle et versé c'est une force politique
qui commence à grandir dans ce pays et
puis il faudra bien toute façon que toi
que ça se renouvelle et puis là il ya un
nouveau parti qui est plus proche plus
proche des autres plus proche de
l'environnement regarde en afrique quand
tu vas chez grand père chez papy passer
des gens qui vivent pas pareil avec leur
environnement sont des verts aussi celle
des écolos sont les gens qui au
quotidien vivre dans une autre relation
qui sont pas dans une hystérie de la
productivité comme certains bon il ya
des avantages et des inconvénients
tu as vu quand tu vas chez papy il
faudrait pas d'eau chaude c'est bien son
papy j'aime bien léché papilles et papa
c'est vrai qu'il faut plus manger de
danone ah oui ça c'est vrai ah c'est
vrai parce qu'à l'école on m'a dit on
mange plus de danane chez nous on mange
plus de danane rien pourquoi parce qu'il
faut partir et c'est mauvais ça donne la
chiasse
papa j'ai entendu évitons ancien copain
qui a dit à la radio que tu pensais
qu'au fric bah oui parce qu il fallait
bien qu'ils trouvent quelque chose mais
tu sais bombe à lui il a vendu beaucoup
de cassettes aille beaucoup plus
d'impôts peut pas donc ça m'énerve un
petit peu près mais bon c'est son copain
pas d'accord c'est quand même son copain
balawi un copain reste encore pas bien
il vaut mieux aimer jésus ou coluche
sont les mêmes ce sont deux grands
humoristes de l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
et papa comment roule un joint
tiens va chercher la boîte là bas
et papa pourquoi on meurt
c'est très important c'est très
important ça arrive à un moment où tu
prévois pas et c'est mieux comme ça et
est pas si tu leur pas tu vis par toi
c'est la mort ça n'existe pas si on
vient obligé de mourir en fait c'est une
mauvaise question je sais pas qui tu as
posé cette question ça allait passer à
l'école c'est la petite lapide semoun
petit cerveau c'est la petite semoun qui
m'a dit de mandji à ton père
j'ai téléphoné à son père sont mal
élevés ces gens c'est parce que tu vas
mourir que tu rigole moins qu'avant
non tu sais je rigole toujours autant tu
m'as vu quand même bon à la maison c'est
vrai que tu as fait des bêtises aussi
c'est normal que je rigole pas tous
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai je risque ma
puce enfin
enfin non non tu sais papa il a toujours
rigoler on a tout ce qui t'a il n'avait
pas passé le jour où tu m'as trouvé en
train de lire minutes tu te souviens
voyez quand ton frère est rentré dans la
police
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu